I think this is a classic rock pose with
the eyebrows that signature eyebrow look
at that and this is your kind of this is
the kind of a pre-match is this the
pre-match yeah that's like the it's the
pre-match it's the preamble it's a
talking trash that is a I had a
catchphrase that that that went with is
not that it doesn't matter that's it
doesn't matter how did it doesn't matter
what cuz it doesn't sound like a
catchphrase how did it work as a
catchphrase well uh whoever I was in the
ring with and stupids been there are
many occasions right so whoever I was in
the ring with so for example if it were
you and I'd be like um Graham what do
you think you're gonna do tonight when
we get in the ring well I think matter
that's how it kind of works and then
it's the shouting of ivali if you smell
if you know what The Rock is cooking how
did that work then in in a sentence
oh well that that works in a sentence a
statement a question it works anywhere
right when you wake up right when before
you go to bed it's just you could just
say it if you smell what The Rock is
quicker yeah but you gotta say it
probably with a little bit like you know
little shout that one as well
mmm it's hard I generally have a
microphone while I'm doing it whoa hello
go for it I don't know they don't want
to hear me okay all right here we go so
it's it's all starts with the bass okay
okay
got to open your legs a little bit okay
okay you got to kind of do one of these
yeah lean forward a little bit yeah come
back if you're samaa and then right here
is where you gotta get do a little
tongue thing okay this is what it gets
interesting
did you smell them you got it now you
got to do that what the rock and then
there's a little pause there's like a
big pregnant pause that you have to do
so the audience kind of leans in a
little bit is cooking and then
obvious thing is is it drew this
comic-con was sort of part of your
honeymoon
oh yeah that's yes and I put I found a
bumper sticker in the shape of a pot
plan that said [ __ ] cops